the conflict between Russia and Ukraine
is a territorial dispute and one that
the U.S cannot fund for as long as it
takes
well those were the words from likely
presidential candidate Ron DeSantis
earlier this week
now for that eminently reasonable take
on the matter the D.C warhawks Unleashed
on him
Governor DeSantis who I don't know do
this like super soft peddling of the
language I find very very troubling it
was troubling to hear some on the hard
right not so much not condemn Putin so
much as excusive the Trump wing of the
Republican party has decided to turn its
back on Democracy they have tremendous
affection for dictators
to these lunatics even hear themselves
on the left what happened to being the
anti-war party they've all sold out now
while there was some criticism from the
GOP establishment as well the positions
Ron DeSantis and Donald Trump are
defining are you know have are defining
the future of the Republican party now
according to the polling outfit Echelon
insights the GOP is trending away from
viewing Ukraine as vital to U.S
interests and perhaps more interestingly
younger Republicans are much less
interested in an assertive U.S foreign
policy in general joining us now is John
Radcliffe former Director of National
Intel under President Trump John
for DeSantis to say it's a territorial
dispute and we can't stay there
for as long as it takes both of those
Physicians
are correct as as factual matters are
they not
well Laura listen let's start with I
talked to all kinds of Republicans and
all Republicans agree on this that this
is an unnecessary War Putin has invaded
Ukraine twice both times Joe Biden has
been in the White House and so I think
where Republicans are disagreeing is
this is Joe Biden's mess now how do we
fix it how do we get out of this and
what you hear Ron DeSantis and Donald
Trump and others saying is really that
there's a crisis in leadership here that
there's zero confidence in Joe Biden as
commander-in-chief he's had zero success
and so there's zero confidence in him
you know he uh you know he he was a
disaster uh as commander-in-chief in
Afghanistan and then now let's look at
this a policy or strategy with regard to
Ukraine first it uh it started out as
there wasn't going to be a war because
he was going to deter Putin then he was
okay with a small incursion then when
Putin actually invaded uh he said
essentially I'm willing to surrender
Ukraine by giving zelinski a ride out of
town and now he's gone 180 degrees the
other way and saying this is a fight to
the death that's not an inconsistent
strategy Laura that is schizophrenic and
and what you hear Republicans saying is
as he toggles back and forth between
between strategies that he doesn't have
he can't execute on any of them and
that's where I think Republicans but
John really see the problem with with
Ukraine but John I think it's bigger
than that I think this language as long
as it takes I mean that's a nice
sentiment but name name the recent you
know conflict that we've stayed in quote
as long as it takes Afghanistan Iraq
I mean I guess Grenada right Vietnam
that's just ridiculous I mean if it goes
on 25 years is in Putin is able to get
money from China and keep it going for
20 years they really think the American
people are going to support that is
Lindsey Graham and all these guys out of
their minds
absolutely not and what what folks like
Lindsey Graham think is look let's just
keep sending more uh weapons to Ukraine
and eventually they can ridiculous this
goes back to the point of can can Joe
Biden lead an international uh uh group
uh uh our allies to to victory in in
Ukraine by supporting Ukraine and the
answer is uh increasingly Republicans
say no he's had no success he's he's
been in abysmal failure he's been
bullied by Russia he's been bullied by
China he hasn't stood up for America and
to put uh that much confidence in a
Biden Administration as
commander-in-chief uh really is just uh
is is not resonating with Republicans
John great to see you tonight thank you
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else